Tommy Boy I mean
that seen as the cow tipping scene yes
um I'm from Ohio cow tipping is a real
thing
we really do it the writers of that show
could not believe they thought I was
making it up they thought it was a bit I
told them about it and they put that
scene in the script and that was my
contribution to the script of Tommy Boy
I mean
and Chris Farley amazing oh my God I
loved him so much I would take him to
dinner he would order two steaks two
porterhouse steaks and on top of each
bite he would put a cube of butter
and when I would look at him and be like
Chris what are you doing it needs a hat
a butter hat a butter hat butter hat oh
my gosh Julia Child says yes yes